salut à tous c'est pêcheur de trésor
alors on est de retour au canal du Ron
ou canal Philippe lamour ça dépend c'est
ça vous reconnaissez sûrement la
passerelle il y avait vraiment plein de
choses c'est un endroit qui a jamais été
fait et comme la dernière fois on est en
compagnie de la team ESM pêcheur de
trésor on espère faire de belles
trouvailles il y avait un fusil ici la
dernière fois il y en a sûrement
d'autres et surtout qu'est-ce que
Quentin tu veux trouver un coffre fort
ici un coffre fort ouis c'est la mission
du jour franchement ça se fait ouais
c'est un coin criminel c'est faisable
allez ben c'est parti et bien sûr on est
en compagnie de rasta qui est à l'ombre
là en face c'est bien atttion de pas
tomber partie de
tu dis direct là ça nous mettra en forme
ouais alors alors alors alors oh wou il
est rempli hein il en reste il est
rempli on a rien de d'incroyable à part
une [__] de vélo ouais le petit
tournevis il y avait pas mal d'outils là
aussi ou ouais un poid
intéressant W W W c'est ça il y a une
corde ouais une un câble en acier oui
acier ouis des
ver pas mal de chos normalement oh joli
ah
oui catalytique non c'est un scooter ça
ou non moi aussi j'ai quelque chose vous
êtes
prêts
waouh çait de la connerie
ouais ça c'est quoi là je pense que ça
va pas arrêté aujourd'hui
encore il y a du
poids c'est un moteur la barre de j'ai
un moteur de
scooter bar et une sacrée barre a ah
ouais de de mob un caniche un ancien
caniche de Mamie il reste que des poils
c'est vra que ça fait un peu cheveux
dégueulasse ouais finalement
ouais maintenant que tu le dis
ouais perruque
non on dirait une perruque non avec un
masque possible ouais une mauvaise
blague d'alloui ouais c'est les masques
qui font peur là de clown
ouais c'est possible al pourquoi dans le
canal pour faire peur au pêcheurs
allémand ouais ou un braquage age il y a
un film comme ça où ils sont en
clown peut-être qu'ils avaient le fusil
aussi ils ont tou jé en même temps ouais
benah du coup c'était une sorte de
peau ça c'est quoi ça ah c'est un bout
de vélo le pédalier des chaussettes ah
ça regarde une chicha ah
ouais la petite chicha qui fait plaisir
ouais al regardz un vieux F passé bon
c'est pas ce en fonte quand même mais ça
reste
ancien beau vélo ah tu qu'est-ce que tu
nous sors alors qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça une chaise oh là là il y a vraiment
n'importe quoi ici c'est
terrible ah ici belle députion en tout
cas ça fait plaisir suis content de ma
chaise
là et là regardez un cadre de
mobylette j'is tout drit bien joué c'est
quoi 100 Peugot 103 ça non ouais on
dirait bien ouais al on sait qu'on a
beaucoup d'amateurs dans les abonnés qui
aimeraient avoir des cadres comme ça
mais ils sont vraiment abîmés hein
désolé pour vous ouais ben merci donc on
est sur un spot de voleur de mobylette
des années 70 sûement alors un garde
debout là-bas et
ici je viens de faire de monnaes oh joli
ah du franc alors je crois qu'elle est
bleue la 78
et une de Fran ok combi mo-til celle-là
non oua ouais et 200 centimes
c'est bon signe he parce
que ouais c'est pas ici qu'on fait
forcément des vœux c'est un peu bizarre
comme endroit ah mais c'est bon signe
des pièces
ouais il était tout au fond celui-là et
il y a du
poids oh là là moi aussi je suis TR oh
là là c'est encore du vélo oh
une grosse barre encore un
caleçon comme on disait avec tout à
l'heure objectif plus de 300 kg ouais à
5 on devrait les faire làà on y
croit oh c'est un couteau je l'avais pas
vu celuilà il est beau manche en bois
pas très vieux ça qu'il faut bien
checker ton ou oui
Colombia si vous connaissez les couteaux
Colombia vas-y
de quoibas non jingl compagnie ça sonne
un peu chinois ça par contre
unu mais bon c'est bien je garde pour
les collectionneur de couteau ouais il a
l'air bien aiguisé en
plus c'est lour ouais ça vient
ou ça vient en
fait le poids mais c'est quand qu'on le
voit là vous avez dit 300 kg GAE à tes
mains vatis pas devant les mains
allez ah ouais ça a lâché ça rigole pas
vous avz vu ce que c'était vachement
lourd non même pas c'était pas loin de
sortir et il y avait pas de trace
d'essence non après la première
mobylette une deuxième Piaggio Piaggio
un Piaggio ou exactement au même endroit
non ouaisiment il y a autre chose ici
autre chose elles sont elles sont
entassé ouais alors qu'est-ce qu'on a de
beau ici
ouis une
pince elle marche toujours c'est bon ça
une petite pince oh merde a
a j'ai un peu raté l'eau je
crois ah
ouais super des bijisoux bien joué là tu
as une montre la marque de la montre
Rodania ok tu as une mon ensemble ouais
une montre montre femme ça ouais ça a
été donné par un garage c'est Rodania et
bon ben bien une Casio
c'est c'est viéement ça normalement les
Casio elles sont étanches mais là tu
vois qu'elle a quand même pris un peu ça
doit faire tellement longtemps et toutes
ces pièces du coup donc des Frans
collector et pas que non que des
collectors ouais c'est que
ouais [__] ça ça fait les bras he
soleil là oh [__] c'est dangereux ça
ouais c'est ça très très dangereux c'est
mal un peu
allez
go attends je vais envoyer un autre s la
mobylette ouais mobylette entière on
dirait euh ouais peut-être faut
voir ah ouais c'est gros hein attends je
peux attacher aussi alors on a l'aide de
de Eric et popeille qui va envoyer le
grappin ah parce que là on a peur que
les mains ils lâchent et qu' retombe
surtout h ouais c'est une lame d'un
coute de cuisine non mais
non ah dommage ah quoi que ah tuas eu un
bout ah mais c'est ouais il s coupé en
deux a deux ou il y en a de ici façon il
y a plein de morceaux toute façon
l'autre il est lourd peut-être qu'il y a
les deux roues au final a de ce dessus
ah ouais ils sont tenus ah [__] ça
tire tout attends c'est scout
ouais il y a un scoot là-bas avec plus
que le cadre du coup et pas entier c'est
la roue c'est la roue arrière qui va
peser ouais ouais ouais voilà tac est-ce
que je peux continuer à tirer un peu moi
merde nickel ah mince le réservoir s'en
va
ouaess le choper après
voilà vous
voulez
ça pas vous faire mal derrière ok bon
c'est sympa nickel il y a des roues
minuscules hein h c'est
si vous savez quel modè c'est en
commentaire oh oui une grosse pile allez
de la bonne
dépollution qu enfer de jeter ça dans le
canal ils ont pas
honte n'importe quoi tout ce qu' a une
poignée de vélo et un morceau de pot de
mobylette alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
Deb moteur ça ouais encore un moteur de
mobyette ok si vous savez moteur de quoi
c'est diteslemoi en commentaire alors
qu'est-ce que tu nous sors là je peux
même pas l'annoncer mais je pense qu'il
y aura au moins une barre de fer ça je
peux je peux te le certifier un morceau
de scooter sement franchement il y a du
poids ça va c'est intéressant ah c'est
encore plein ici ouais on va regarder ce
qu'on
a c'est des il y a des morceaux de cadre
il y a un peu de tout là il y a de tout
ouais des morceau de câble de cadre de
la fonte là il y a un truc peut-être une
forme intéressante c'est un portable non
ah ça c'est une écreviss ah ouais mais
du coup cette fois-ci ah si c'est encore
une de louisian non non non c'est une
blanche ouais là c'est une blanche donc
on peut la relâcher elle ve bien
lâcherouis elle veut pas te lâcher on
voit ell sont différentes un peu ouais
ouais ou h regarde ah non beaucoup dur
elle a pris cher c'est bon elle était en
vie quand elle est tombée et là je
voulais voir ça c'est un portable ah oui
mais c'est un smartphone ça il est tout
fin il est tout explosé surtout B c'est
mais c'est bien tu vois ils avaient
gardé la vitre de protection ouais donc
est-ce qu'elle a fonctionné attention
enlèvela pour voir ah dommage dommage
ouais ouais c'est quand même assez vieux
OK et un couteau attends attends attends
il y a un chlace tu as vu tu l'as
relâché lui aussi ouais il est tombé tu
as fait comme les crevises ouais pareil
il a fait la même trajectoire tu es
vraiment bizarre c'est cool ça on va
rester camper de ce côté un peu on oui
on va jeter tout là là on est bien ici
mon j'arrive la corde est accrochée sur
un gros objet donc là on va sortir le
treuil on va l'installer ici euh on va
voir si ce panneau il est assez bien
ancré dans le sol sûrement oui à la base
il a l'air bien costaud sinon on le
mettra sur l'échelle et l'objectif c'est
de remonter l'objet avec cette corde
donc le long de la pente bon est-ce que
ça bule toujours pas tu tires là déjà
ouais ça me paraî logique que so
lour ça lourd
mie mais ça vient ah oui ça sinon la ce
aurait lâché
ouais bon allez on est au bout donc va
devoir défaire et refaire un autre nœud
plus
loin alors ça vient le poids du
machin on est déjà au bout ça serv à
rien
ça buûle un peu regarde ça buûle pas
mais ça fait de la terre ils ont déjà
sorti des tonnes de cadres cette fois W
une qui all entière ah oui là c'est plus
lourd
là ouais le grappin est bien dedans déjà
oh [__] c'est normal c'est moi qui
l'ai lancé ouais c'est bon tu une
médailles bon ben c'est parti hein je
suis pas trop bien dessus oh [__] ah
ouais
B il a l'air de flter
hein à peine
ah ouais
il y a la plaque il y a clairement la
plaque les gars on essaie de le décaler
ou de le soulever non vaut mieux le
décaler seraz de directement VO là
regardez ils amèent la moto au
bord pas l' lour votre moto les
gars c'est original ça de promener son
scooter un petit comme un gros poisson
tenu en
l' attendez je passe avec ma corde
là-bas en face passer là
a est venu au première loge pour
assister à la sortie du scooter ouais on
va y arriver ah oui là le plus dur est
fait en
vrai 1 2 3
ouais c'est un scooter c'est un garçon
c'est un garçon
ouais c'est vra qu' pas la roue avant
ouais c'est
vrai elle doit pas être loin bien loin
mais bien joué les
gars bien jou joué bien
joué alors Digita
Digita et la plaque va regarde ouais bah
tu sais que c'est pas si vieux dB dB
c'est quelle année ah pas non c'est pas
si vieux c'est une nou c'est une plaque
récente
hein on pas récupér piè du coup non vol
un peu pour rien ils ont dû juste
s'amuser avec et làdedans est-ce qu'il y
a quelque chose et ben il y a rien il a
des gens làdedans tuas
pas à la recherche de gens ouais ça
donne envie d'aller voir mais bon
ouais ben je suis pas sûr que l'ACUE
soit ouais je pense qu'il serait pas
content pendant que Quentin est en train
de cuire sous la chaleur j' peu plus on
a la 7è mobilette qui est en train
d'arriver qu'est-ce que tu en penses
Quentin pendant que nous on a S
pas grand chose là-bas non mais là-bas
c'est mort
là-bas
103 un beau bleu avec un sac poubelle
magnifique en
plus a a a a a tout doucement a a a bon
ou on est
bon c'est pas bien joué il y a un
autocant dessus dirit
ou
ça me rappelle ma jeunesse ça oui
comme ça me tire ça c'est si lourd
c'est
là c'est super
lourd rien ça ça l'
fait
r ça vient là allez jusqu'à un certain
point allez ça
vient
allez c'est une énorme barrière c'est
une échelle une barrière c'est une cage
de
prison en fait elle est très
longue vous m'emportez ah ouais vous
pouvez pas tirer là non c'est bon ti on
se met là-bas on se décale un peu ici 1
3 1 2
3 2
3 on est
presque
allez 1 2
[__] on POS POS on
pose ah c'est un château fort le BO il
va tomber bientôt c'est on est presque
là a une chaise ouais il a tellement de
trucs incroyable ça tu ça tue allez on
va y arriver onue allez on y arrive 1 2
3 allez 1 2 3
allez 2 3 ah là c'est trop dur
3 2
3 ah
[__] 2
3 on est presque oui il y a une moto au
bout
une c'est n'importe quoi là allez on est
presque tu m vou de la ah ben là les 300
kg voilà 1 2
3 faut monter dessus aller chercher la
mobylette
ou marche
pas ça ça déjà on peut le récupérer
ça ah c'est bon j'ai arraché une
partie voilà ça
moin ça aussi le poid de ça par rapport
la grille c'est négligeable ouais mais
quand
même on va finir de la tirer on va dire
c'est la ou ah ben quand
même bien je comprends pourquoi on
galérit quand
même la forme du Mach la
taille ça c'est une prière si vous
voulez faire une prison ça parfait hein
c'est
clair portail carrément portail ouais
clairement on
continue ceux qui font des des escape
game prison et tout
làendre la grille on
finit tu fini seul non tu arrives là non
seul avec to ce ce qui est chiant c'est
ce truc dessous tu peux pas l'enlever
non non tu peux pas ah une nouvelle
mobylette la 8e la 8e
mais là l'utilitaire il va déborder
aujourd'hui il y avait un vrai gang de
voleurs de mobile c'est incroable si
c'est vous dénoncez-vous il y a
prescription attention belle
trouvaille c'est rien dis c'est bien
allez biens ou qu' a une grille oui on
l' sorti chi les chi la grosse grille
ouais on en a ché la grosse grosse
Grou est la VO on sor ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle est tomb non mais sérieux
peut-être 30 ans ouis on en a
ch allez la vendre si vous voulez ouais
ça fait 30 ans qu'on essaie de la sortir
gentil ouis aussi lour mais ti yanky
jade allez hop hop jade allez on va
là-bas vous dites 1 ouais c'est dur on
tire l'expert
vas-y c'est quand même plus pratique
avec l'utilitaire ouais c'est
[Musique]
bon allez
un de
plus combien du coup on a dit une
dizaine 10 je vous êtes beaucoup à nous
demander ce que l'on fait de toute la
ferraille que l'on ramasse même si
certains d'entre vous le savent déjà on
accumule toute la ferraille dans un
garage et on la vend au poids chez un
ferrailleur lorsque c'est nécessaire
aujourd'hui on a donc décidé de vous
emmener avec nous chez le ferrailleur on
va voir combien de kilos de ferraill on
arrive à vendre mais surtout combien on
va en tirer bon dans un premier temps
c'est la tâche la plus fastidieuse il
faut remplir le camion heureusement
cette fois-ci on a un camion plateau et
on a été aidé par notre ami Marc encore
un grand merci pour ton aide
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant de se dire que tout
ça était dans l'eau vous pouvez voir la
quantité de cadre de scooter incroyable
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Marc c'est
sûr c'est de fou et il en reste il en
reste on va continuer à charger je pense
pas qu'on a le temps de tout faire sur
cette allée là vu la taille du TS
encore mais bon c'est déjà un bon début
c'est déjà pas mal allez on continue le
fameux clic clac et le camion qui se
remplit pas mal on commence à être bien
là c'est chaud là-dessus he garder la
quantité voilà pour le
chargement je me demande combien il a en
poids on va voir ça rapidement il en
reste un peu dans le garage mais c'est
déjà très bien regardez-moi ce camion
qu'on a rempli bon on l' sanglé c'est
pas top mais ça va la fer ou Bou et
cette fois-ci on va essayer de ne pas
prendre d'amende puisque c'est vrai que
ça c'était un petit peu mal passé la
dernière fois on avait quand même payé
90 € d'Amand pour on voir s'il en fait
tomber dans le rond-point pour un excès
de vitesse ouais là c'est le test du
rond-point ah il va doucement il va
doucement il est il est
sérieux bon tu par sur combien là dans
lequel en tout en tout alors du coup moi
je dirait dans les TI 1 ton 5 ouais donc
combien
100 80
200 € allez 200 € on
espère ça c'est de la grue mon pote he
là il y a de la
gruir vas-y ça va
[Musique]
venir enlè le
pi c
c
attention
vas-y ça va le faire ça va virasy
continue
continue c'est
la ça c'est
la
oh joli ça
ouais au
sommet il en
reste
ça c'est de
l'a c'est cment qu' nous faut
là
ouais
1550 1550 kg on avit 1500 215 € ouais
c'est pile ce qu'on avait dit il y a un
camion qui attend nickel on sort et on
se met dehors ouais vas-y ouvre
ouais tu recules
ouvreouvre merci j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu ben nous on
reviendra clairement il en reste et vous
vous avez pas sorti votre coffre fort
aussi on sa pas on sait pas s'il y en a
dites-nous en commentaire si vous voulez
une partie 3 en tout cas un grand merci
à la team sm pêcheur de trésor voilà le
lien de le réseau son en description ils
sont en live sur TikTok tous les
dimanches si je me trompe pas quasiment
tous les dimanches par que sinon pour
sortir ça on aurait pas plus là c'était
impossible à de déjà à 4 c'était très
compliqué
donc allez bah à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à
l'ément